good afternoon we start with breaking
news a transformer explosion at hoover
dam thick black smoke and fire rising
from one of the generator houses as
tourists and others look on from above
that was the scene earlier this morning
over at the dam and certainly things are
well it's not like this right now this
is video uh from earlier at the dam
itself we thank you for joining us here
on eight news now i'm john langler the
fire was reported about 10 30 this
morning boulder city fire says the fire
was put out really before they got there
let's go to david charns who is live at
the scene right now dave what can you
see
[Music]
yeah john we're on the i-11 bridge which
you know goes over the colorado river
it's right next to hoover dam and as you
see here we'll zoom down and show you
where this fire was as you mentioned
it was at a transformer area next to one
of the power generation buildings now
we're going to show you that video from
earlier where the transformer exploded
around 10 this morning witnesses seeing
it from where i'm standing right now you
see a big plume and smoke and fire there
the alarms were going off we have
confirmed the transformer did explode on
the arizona side of the dam here as i
mentioned the turbines inside there are
about a dozen of them on both sides of
the river here they make power
hydropower clearly something went wrong
and that transformer exploded but
exactly what went wrong we don't have
the answer to yet all we know is there
was a fire and when boulder city fire
crews got here it was out
keep in mind though even though i'm
wearing a fleece on this very hot day it
is above 100 degrees there were people
standing where i am on the overpass here
watching but at this point you wouldn't
know that there was a fire a lot of
people exploring the dam everything
pretty much back to normal john back to
you
david i spoke with someone at the
boulders at the boulder dam hotel in
boulder city and they had heard that
tourists were coming back to town
because they weren't allowed at the dam
anymore but you're saying it's open back
up again people can walk around not only
where you are on the tillman bridge but
down on the dam itself
yeah clearly not in tourist gear today
but
we were able to get through boulder dam
security
no one pretty much said anything and a
lot of people who we've talked to who
are on the overpass here because as you
see you get this gorgeous view of the
dam and then what happened below no one
seems to actually know a lot of tourists
don't know there was a transformer
explosion here so a scary moment at
about 10 this morning but everything
back to normal john david final question
can you tell if they're generating power
right now does seem things look normal
the water coming down from the bottom of
the dam everything seems about right
yeah so what i remember from going on
this tour a couple months ago is you see
the water there sort of brewing
next to those turbine houses there
turbine houses there means water is
flowing through the system and they are
generating power we did hear from the
reclamation the bureau of reclamation
they say power generation is not
affected by this in any way so this was
just one incident and we're now waiting
to hear the cause john
david thank you very much and try and
get cool we know it's very hot out there
appreciate it now here is some video
from 2017 the exact area where the
explosion happened today again this is
from back in 2017 there you see the
transformers the turbines and so forth
again no one was hurt and as david just
mentioned tours have already resumed at
hoover dam